which one is faster mac or pc well to  date we will find out once in for all  with this custom built water cooled pc  that has an intel 12 900k and an rtx  3090 so let's go ahead and jump right in  i was shocked by how snappy this system  was it scored 290 in speedometer 2.0  which is insanely fast and that's  because a single core actually beats out  the max studios m1 ultra and when we  switch to multi-core it does get beat  out now when we jump into cinebench the  12 900k actually beats out now when it's  doing that the fans just go crazy of  course if you want to play games you  definitely should buy the pc now on the  flip side the mac studio is the way to  go for people that code if you want to  do 3d rendering and you care about speed  definitely go for the pc for photo  editors the mac studio is super fast for  video editing as long as you're only  using one gpu on your pc this mac studio  is awesome